[Music]
welcome to cmp 302 we're gonna do some
benchmarking of GCE on this well GCP but
mostly GC is census
this session is Dory enabled please save
your questions for the end and please
use the Dory and it'll be moderated
after the session so what's in store for
you we'll be talking first about a
perfect benchmark err perfect kid
benchmark err is an open source project
at Google where we're trying to make a
set of tools to make benchmarking easy
for everyone trying to figure out which
cloud provider to use then we're gonna
go over a slew of benchmarks probably
too many data slides I don't know how I
got them approved but there's a vast
number of slides it'll show IAS
benchmarks in many ways then last week
we announced the c2 it's a new instance
type at Google or at GCE and I'll be
sure comparing that to our older and one
instances and we'll see if performance
is better or if it's different on the c2
versus the n1 spoilers slightly better
and then I'll be giving you a couple
demos and some scripts to take home that
are pretty easy to use if you want to
compare and contrast different instances
different almost anything you want to
slice and dice IAS pretty easily okay
what is PK be like I said it's an open
source set of tools that we've created
to try and make it easy to compare the
performance of various components of the
cloud platforms it supports most cloud
providers it has on the order of 50
different tests that you can run to try
and get performance data on the
different providers or the different
services I think it's particularly good
at getting IAS we've worked can we
started working with GCE pretty early on
this project and we think we hit most of
the major touch points that people are
interested in with respect to
performance for GCE we also have a
number of tests for ml which are being
added constantly I've put more resources
over time into our ml tests
they test all the different
configurations bgp UTP you or just
running on the processor itself we also
do database tests some the database
testing is a big art and we are
continually expanding our set of tests
for data for databases but it's not
complete at this point we need a it's
just a vast amount of work to get them
all complete but we're working on it and
then we have some big data tests so some
tests that hit bigquery data proc data
flow and a bunch of other services and
compare and contrast them but these
services are a little bit bespoke
sometimes so comparing them can be a
little bit difficult but we give it a
shot and you know please try it and tell
us what you think
some random stats about PKB it's
moderately successful project you know
we have a little over 300 Forks we have
1.5 K watch star Forks we get on the
order of 3.7 K commits so 4,000 commits
and about 100 contributors across a
number of a number of companies what I
really get a kick out of though is quite
often when I see an industry report come
out from one of the big vendors and I
look at the addendum or the appendix and
I can see how they did it it's pretty
common now that I'm seeing PK be
referenced and used as scripts to
generate their reports which is it's
starting to get more and more use for
benchmarking especially like I said IAS
is being infrastructure as a service so
vm's networking disk will go over those
so why do you want to benchmark the
cloud well
performance is usually one of the three
top performer metrics that people use
when trying to decide what cloud to go
to security obviously top of mind it's
been in every keynote very very
important reliability availability very
much top of mind benchmarking that is
model difficult we'll talk about that
near the end but that's also top of mind
but performance or price performance
quite commonly is right up there in
purchase decisions so it's moderately
important the best way to get
performance data is by doing Pio
seas of course so you take all of your
apps you somehow come up with some model
where you can bundle the good percentage
of them up the crucial parts that you
believe you moving up to the cloud and
you run that the problem with POCs is
that they're quite expensive and they're
very they're just complicated /
expensive so they're the best but
expensive is there something you can do
beforehand maybe kick the tires it's
cheaper yes especially like I said is
the models are pretty simple for
figuring out how is works is is
unbelievably complicated underneath the
hood but from a user's perspective when
you think about the performance
characteristics it's not overly
complicated so we can both a bunch of
tests that allow people to compare and
we'll see a bunch of this and it's
moderately easy and inexpensive so we're
gonna be hitting five main metrics on is
boot time it's a weird one I know at
first you're gonna wonder why boot time
I'll go into why boot time is important
after that we'll talk about compute VMS
are the dominant expense for almost
every person who uses cloud and what do
you do on VM generally compute that's
probably in many ways the most important
metric memory a little bit of a fringe
metric but it can show you sometimes
some interesting characteristics and
again incredibly easy to run and
moderately easy to interpret so might as
well kick the tires networking the VMS
are in the cloud networking sending
bytes receiving bytes is what they do
incredibly important depending upon the
app could be crucial many compute apps
are actually latency bound and if you do
a lot of HPC in the cloud there's a
number of reasons why network is
important serving so incredibly
important and actually shockingly
complex from our perspective again we're
just gonna do performance but there's so
many ways to slice it as we'll see is I
just inundate you with slides and data
that there's a lot to compare when it
comes to networking and finally remote
block block devices or disks you need
you need to boot your machines
you gotta fetch data from somewhere it's
either from usually cloud storage or
from your block device pretty important
in some scenarios especially databases
where databases hammer
or their mobile device incredibly hard
and knowing how the block device
responds under this kind of hammering
for databases especially but all kinds
of solutions be it no sequel databases
or traditional databases remote discs
can be right front and center with
respect to how your overall lap performs
so benchmarking remote discs is pretty
important all right boot times like I
said kind of a weird one to start with
you'd think compute so why boot times
well the first thing is that they're the
customers first experience when they get
onto the cloud I have a really quick
story about this that I find funny
friend of mine has an m/l startup he's
doing moderately well he's on some cloud
provider and another cloud provider came
in and gave him sufficient credits to
run his all of his apps for two years so
he was as CEO and the guy who was
impossible for the finances he was
totally bought in and he told his devs
we're moving to this other cloud the
other cloud had not the best boot times
in particular actually there were a
number of other issues but boot times
really irritated the devs it irritated
them so much that somehow and I still
know how this possible they rebelled
against the CEO and they stayed with
their other provider where they were
paying money to this day both he and I
are incredibly confused how this all
played out but it's an amazing story as
to why boot times are moderately
important as VM lifetime shortened just
rationally as VM a lifetime shorten the
boot time becomes more and more
important and I'm gonna show some data
both how internally when we view all of
your workloads how commonly how long you
keep machines up and then we'll show how
internally for us how long we keep
machines up and then aspirationally
where we think we should go on that and
finally it really does show boot time
showed technical excellence they hit the
whole stack you hit the top of the
control plane you hit the job scheduling
you hit network programming which is
crazy complicated pd programming and you
hit the actual data plane to get the
bytes onto the machine and the machine
to get booted and if you can drive that
time down
it just shows technical excellence
throughout the entire stack I think it's
an important
the important metric so then I'll show
you some great crazy graphs of where our
boot times are today
and then I'll show you if you can boot
if you can measure this yourself
assuming my laptop keeps powered
lifespan of VMs so today this is what
you guys do in our cloud today this is a
CDF I should tell you actually this is
my favorite you're gonna see way too
many CDF today a CDF shows at a given
percentile what the value of interest is
so in this case on the vertical axis it
shows you the percentile being zero to
100% and along the horizontal axis that
is hours of duration of the VM you can
see it has a pretty sharp slope and your
P 50 for all of your workloads is 12
minutes that is the median time of a VMs
life today in GCE
pretty short you would think and it's
pretty short and you're doing it not
wrong at all I think you're doing it
exactly right the entire idea behind
moving to cloud is that it's incredibly
responsive and agile and you can just
use that you can use compute the second
you need it and then you discard it and
it doesn't cost you anything after that
this is the exact right way to use it
and you're using it right and this is
what we do in Google internally in
Google internally we're doing the same
thing you are
and that's when we need compute we spin
a container up for us but we spin up a
container and then as soon as that
computes necessary we throw it away so
someone else can use it and we're down
to six minutes here and we actually
think that aspirationally in GCE we
should drive this time down even more we
love to think of we think aspirationally
that VM should be thought of like
threats and that you should be able to
spin up a VM in a sub second that's the
whole stack and then should be throw it
away as soon as you don't need it this
is the we think this is the future we're
driving towards it but like I said this
is a full stack problem and it's
moderately hard here's why it's a full
stack problem and it's moderately hard
this is from our internal monitoring
this shows at a high level each one of
these lines shows like a large section
of code that is responsible during a VM
boot up bring up and if I click on this
in our internal modern these expand
infinitely into even more
or subsections that show that are broken
down but this is the high-level view and
what contributes to boot times it's of
course the control plane the control
plane itself is incredibly complicated
it has to do a ton of business logic it
has to then do in a really weird number
of quota management it is strange how
many different quotas are modified in
the construction of a VM then that is
sent off to the actual job scheduler
well I'm on my demo a little early sorry
then it goes onto the job scheduler and
the job scheduler will find a place for
that a physical place for that VM we
have as you know custom VM types this
makes it so we have a bin packing
problem to solve globally for the
cluster every time you schedule a VM we
batch it up a little bit to make it so
it isn't terribly compute-intensive
but yeah so we have to find a physical
place for it then once it finds the node
a lot of containers and C groups have to
be set up there's a lot of computation
that has to happen on the node to get it
ready then in the background we start
programming the incredibly complicated
virtual networking while we get the bits
onto the machine as quickly as possible
from then we program the remote disk and
we get the machines on to the bits onto
the machine to boot the OS and run
through that and then there's a little
bit of overhead for SSH while we play
around with keys to make it easy for
everyone but anyway the total sum is on
the order of 20 seconds on as a p50 but
is there a distribution yes yes there's
a distribution these are our four main
geographies I'll talk about that in a
second you have au you have the US and
you have Asia on here each one on a
series on a CDF again the CDF percentile
vertical number in question in this term
in this case seconds to boot on the
horizontal and as you can see the p50 if
you have your glasses on it's really
small the p50 is on the order of 20
seconds for both EU and asia and it's a
little bit more maybe 23 for us us is
where it curves a little bit that's due
to our u.s. sones being quite a bit
larger and there's a constant struggle
between the people making optimization
throughout that stock and the problems
they get as these sir as these cells get
larger and larger so there's a constant
struggle this CDF moves back and forth
continually as the poor devs struggle
mightily there is one more you'll see
there's four lines this is an in-house
joke I'm sure where my staff puts Canada
as one of the top Gio's because I'm
Canadian
I am positive and they continually do
this to me all right let's try a demo
pretty quick hopefully
let's do
what all right so what this is doing is
this is running PKB we're launching on
the order of 20 VMs simultaneously out
there into the cloud
these are n1 standard fours and wait
I'll get the results page here this is
from the previous result it'll hopefully
change as PKB does it sting so we're
gonna fan out 20 machines only 20 you
could do hundreds up to you but in this
case I'm gonna do 20 machines will
record the times some script will run to
create a CDF out of this and we will see
the CDF within three minutes
approximately so and most of that time
is spent clean up there's like 1.5
minutes to send out all the machines and
to gather all the data and then right
now it is apt-get updating oh it's
finished it's generating the graphic at
this time and now it's gonna tear down
we should've made the teardown
asynchronous and hidden but this is what
happens when we make demos so yeah so
we're gonna we're gonna span out 20
machines and see if this means the
previous internal metrics that we have
for how fast our boot time is and
hopefully it should finish tearing down
momentarily
like I said PKB is a moderately large
project that allows us this is a pretty
easy script to run the graphics you know
if you're really good at are it's easy
to make the graphics that's probably the
hardest part of this we there are a
number of graphing solutions if you want
to use that in this case like I said I
want to call self-contained so we used
our so anyway oh of course it's already
done so if I reload this Oh God alright
that didn't work out let's go here
should be a link that will be updated oh
my
there you go so this is the current CDF
this is the CDF we just generated of
boot times you'll see at P 50 amazingly
it was at 15 seconds that's pretty good
for us this is running Debian 9 which is
our best OS of course boot time varies
on an OS basis but this is our best all
right back to the slides all right
so compute well this is what you do with
VMs generally so incredibly important
varies on a couple dimensions varies on
skew we're gonna try n 1 versus C to see
if the C 2 is any better
there's also single threaded versus
multi-threaded this corresponds to spec
in speed versus spec in rate spec
enrages almost certainly in almost all
cases much more important but there are
a few fringe cases where spec in speed
is more important also the C 2 is even
better at C 2 at single threaded so I'm
gonna bring it up of course I can try to
sell my C twos and then we're gonna talk
about can we do this easier we can run
spec end it's the granddaddy it's the
best it's the best metric overall for
doing compute but it takes a while it's
moderately expensive to run can we get
something like specint results with some
other tool set and we'll see if that's
possible and then we'll see if we can
measure it ourselves
I'm not sure I'm gonna run a demo though
so it's a little bit faint sadly I might
have to I don't know if you can all see
the light green there's two lines here
on the CDF there is the light green
which is the n1 and there is the dark
green which is the sea to the sea to
spec and speed the single thread
performance is in this metric on a on a
core VMs again this is not perfect
because we are in a zone by ourself and
while the N ones are living with a lot
of other people or other customers so
they're slightly disadvantaged we don't
know if this result will hold once we
get to prod but right now on singleton
performance we're seeing up to 80 60
percent difference between the n1 and
the C 2 which is pretty impressive
you'll note the CDF for the C 2 actually
has a little tail at the bottom there
that's not perfect it should be
perfectly vertical we think what
happened here is that I asked for a
samples from my staff when we cranked it
up to ten in the little tiny zone we had
because it's pre-release and we think we
were making multiple versions of spec
and hit the same socket and specint at
eight cores pretty much saturates the
memory bandwidth of a socket so when you
get multiple they kind of they will
interfere with each other it's just a
it's a known issue with specint and and
normal CPUs you run out of memory
bandwidth it's moderately hungry so
that's sixty percent let's see what
second rate spec and radios like I said
much more important than spec in state
speed for most uses spec in rate is
multi-threaded what is the throughput of
your VM
these are n1 standard AIDS the CDF again
for there's two lines I don't you can
see it all the way in the back one all
the way to the right one closer to the
left again CDF with percentiles and
numbering question at the bottom and the
c2 is doing great
on this case with n1 standard eights or
c2 standard AIDS we're seeing up to 50%
difference at P 50 during our press
release we said 40 percent which is very
safe we think we are pretty safe to say
that most of the time you will get 40
percent at least 40 percent more
performance with a c2 on a per core
basis than you will with an end to with
an n1 rather so it's a pretty big jump
for us it's a I guess I should give a
little bit of a data dump on the c2
itself it's a cascade Lake processor
running with I don't exactly how many
cores but substantially less than we did
inside of the inside of the n1 so
therefore when you go to MCC versus xcc
with Intel or then you go any having
less cores on a per chip means you have
way more TDP per core and you will get
far higher fire higher clock rates and
we do furthermore we did a few other
things
the software is slightly different in
the c2 and the memory is clocked
slightly higher in the c2 than it was in
the n1 and the overall effect is a
tremendous improvement in performance on
a per core basis
all right so uh specint like I said
specint is the granddaddy I'm not gonna
fight specint it's like a hundred PhDs
worked on this for 20 years to come up
with some random bench and set of
benchmarks with some weighting and that
is the best still the gold standard will
I will always run it but is there
anything we can do that could perhaps be
a little bit cheaper than speken
furthermore specking takes like a couple
hours to run to four sometimes 24 hours
to run depend upon VM size and I got
plane to catch
I can't wait for 24 hours I can't do
that with you right here we could fork
all the tests obviously specint is as
you know comprised of on the order of 20
tests 20 to 30 casts we can fork them
all individually bring them all back in
geo mean those and get a number back out
but even then it takes quite a while to
run so what about this why don't we try
running stress ng it's a package out
there which has a variety maybe 50
different tests internally geo mean all
of those together and see what the
result is it turns out it's pretty
correlated with spec end there will be
in the github will give an approximate
correlation coefficient to see how good
stress and G is but it's pretty cheap so
then we'll take a look at that all right
so let's see if we can do that let's go
to the demo but I don't think I'm gonna
make you make you go all the way through
a running of it oh dear
and here we go this is what the end
result is I could have hit the button if
we have time at the end I'll hit the
button for everyone and we can see the
lightens slightly change from left to
right but we got about 55 percent
difference in performance between the c2
or is it 45 in this case between the c2
and the n1 which is within our bounds at
P 50 and the CDF looks beautiful I love
the straight vertical CDF that's what
you want to see in a CDF incredible
consistency and you're getting a little
more consistency on the c2 that we're
running on right away than we do on the
N once and again that's almost certainly
due to a couple factors a little bit
different software in the c2 as compared
to the n1 so we believe that is going to
improve our performance or consistency
and using smaller core counts on a given
socket means you have less probability
of having a neighbor so it's pretty
great
back to the slides all righty
let's do it live and we'll do it live
like I said I'll do it live at the end
if we have time all it takes three
minutes or so all righty
memory there's a bunch of great memory
tests you know anyone who's investigated
this finds like a bajillion of the multi
chase LM bench is great Stream is part
of H PCC and is one of the granddaddy's
of memory performance tests and there's
just a vast array of these will be using
multi chase here because developed at
Google and I have to give my friends
props so we'll try multi chase it's
generally not as useful as a speck or
compute but it can show a few issues it
could show the pneuma support of the VMS
is it perfect or not or they have are
there Newman issues underlying it can
tell if you you can probably look at the
graphs correctly and you squint and you
turn your head you can figure out if
there's host huge page or giant or large
page support like one gig or two Meg
pages you really look you can probably
figure this out and so you can also
figure out if there's some weird kernel
KVM host memory manager issues we're
locking comes into play because quote
once in a while when you do a memory
benchmark you can see some interesting
effect and you can figure out if under
not way underneath the hood there is
some kind of kernel locking bug that is
causing you issues we've got a lot of
mileage out of running these tests over
the years and we found a number of bugs
throughout our stack and perhaps in
others again a little bit faint
I have minimal control of my staff this
is the dark green is the c2 the light
green is the n1 and this is latency of
multi chase so those are in nanoseconds
along the horizontal vertical of course
is always in a CDF is percentile what
can I say other than an enormous
improvement we are talking about big
numbers the p50 was about 142
nanoseconds with the n2 with the n1 and
with the c2 we're talking about 87
nanoseconds which just is about speed of
light given how virtualization works
today at least and the real improvement
is at the tail but we had some real tail
issues with the n1 on memory benchmarks
this was weirdly the tails were not due
to memory itself they were due to
interestingly threads so what would
happen is you have a VC PU thread which
is what backs the seat but you think of
as a CPU within your VM and once in a
while because it's really at the 99
point something up here it's really far
up a user space thread or a kernel
thread would preempt you and this
particular benchmark is very sensitive
and it would detect that and think that
was an incredibly long memory latency a
fetch more precisely while instead it
was just a context which animates the
hood so with the software with the c2 we
have been pretty rigorous in making sure
number one every user space thread
cannot in cannot interfere with ABI CPU
thread because there were some that
we're interfering periodically and
furthermore we have been working
diligently to move every possible kernel
thread out of the way and sequester them
away from Vee CPUs that's a that's an
ongoing battle there will always be a
couple kernel threads that can mess you
up at the p99 point I'm gonna forget
this raid nine nine nine nine nine is
where we're shooting for so it's we're
going to seven nines there there will
always be a couple kernel threads that
can mess you up unless you do drastic
changes but we think we have line of
sight to seven nines we're not there yet
but we're pretty close so anyway that
saying and the other part of the curve
here where we had problems in the n1 as
you can see it's slanted pretty early
not just the extreme tails was Numa
support we didn't have good Numa support
with the n1 with the end to the neumann
support is perfect not too hard we did
it right this time and it's perfect so
if memory latency is crucial to your app
likely you will be buying a c2 demo
let's do it live I'm just gonna show the
graph again because taking three minutes
probably is not right right on so if I
just run this again at the end if I have
an extra couple minutes we'll run these
and you can see that you know this is
exactly the same as the graph we just
ran interestingly I should tell you
about how much these cost to run likes
it
telling you before it's cheap to to run
these tests these tests take on the
order of three to four minutes this is
done with 20 VMs times 2 so 20 C 2 s 20
n one's a seat or an N one takes about
cost at the smaller sizes about 10 cents
each they're running for on the order of
one twentieth of an hour so that's 10
cents per hour multiplied by 40 VMs that
cost you 20 cents so it's not overly
expensive to generate this graph you
could even if you want get a little more
fidelity by cranking up no more
instances if you want the nice smooth
graphs we had earlier to 100 or 200 and
it's gonna cost you a buck so these
aren't horribly hard to create on your
own and it's probably a good investment
back all right
networking we're blowing through the
slides I might have time to run a demo
if I have power all right there are a
vast array of networking tests there's t
tcp and it has a really long set of
descendants that have worked and
branched and slightly changed to TCP
there's iperf everyone's used diaper
it's a pretty much a classic and a lot
of it gives very simple results and
there's net perf net perf is complicated
but the author is pretty cognizant of
just about everything going on with
networking this is why it has on the
order of a thousand switches and he
works at Google is a friend of mine so
I'm gonna use net perf in the following
examples but it's a great test it's just
a little difficult to run considering
the number of flags again pkb will hide
all the flags for you and just output a
bunch of samples that you can throw
through some are scripts or whatever
your favorite visualizer is 15 minutes
left on my laptop and you can then see a
CDF so the networking is super
complicated
these are snags I call them but just
complications there's internal versus
external IPS very different performance
characteristics because the routing is
completely different
there's rate limiters some clouds have
rate limiters on their networking and
that completely changes everything about
how you measure networking if you want
to see where their rate limiters work or
they kick in distance will be going with
distance matters both at the shorts at
the short scale within a data center so
if you can do placement of machines next
to each other that actually saves you a
little bit of time because the switches
involved not due to speed of light but
also distance matters then for how far
your data centers are far from each
other because that will impact
replication speed and of course speed of
light matters in fiber matters a lot for
when you go across continents oh and I
went back second here I forgot fabrics
very we have built over GCE over the
last five years over the five years we
have revved our fabrics time and time
again some of our older zones have older
fabrics which we then Rev but it takes
time so fabrics vary and that changes
that makes TCP Times or Layton sees very
dramatically and finally utilization
utilization varies on a per zone basis
because zones are big and/or small and
just for some reason VMs in some areas
are much more heavily utilized in others
in terms of networking and so you get a
slightly more noisy neighbor effect all
right what does this all look like with
all those caveats this is our intro zone
Interzone networking as you can see this
is a one line per zone and there's a
good amount of difference especially the
tails of those zones that's north
normally do two utilization effects but
there's also differences at the p50 and
most of those are caused by utilization
and by different fabrics there's like
two if you squint maybe you can see two
giant bands in the middle there and that
basically represents a couple of
different generations of network fabric
that we use we are upgrading all of our
zones commonly and the worst ones on
here if I I guess I can say it happen to
be in Asia one we are upgrading those
and we assume they will move slightly
more to the left and again sorry I
should have said what kind of graph this
is I hope this is clear by now
it's a CDF percent vertical horizontal
unit of interest in this case
microseconds and that and at P 50 I
should just I should read the slides I
had notes here we're talking this is P
in most modern zone p50 we're talking 50
microseconds which is pretty reasonable
for for a ping pong latency or TCR are
as this test is called all right this is
gonna be really hard to see I don't know
I might have to walk down there there's
a little red line here if you have your
glasses on I didn't realize how thin
this would be down here for the c2 it's
a little bit faster than everything we
have today this is due to a couple of
reasons I don't know if you can all see
that bits up a little bit over it's at
38 microseconds as opposed to the rest
of our networking this is a why is it a
little bit faster a couple reasons one
obviously the faster frequency of the
processor allows it to really blow
through the TCP stack which is one of
the main components of latency when it
comes to running TCP our are obviously
if you use MPI and some fantastic MPI
library that may or may not be released
soon then that then that all goes away
and these become this time reduces
dramatically but with TCP you need your
processor to power through that very
complicated TCP receive function that
you can go take a look in the kernel
it's hilarious anyway one of the things
that this is using placement groups
placing tubes or rather by happenstance
the c2 it was in very low quantity when
we created all these graphs and the
machines were put very close to each
other physically normally our default
cluster manager configuration is to
spread wide across the entire cell to
make its or zone sorry in GC parlance
across the zone to make a sea of higher
reliability so you haven't got your null
one failure domain will hit two
computers so this is a little bit better
than it would probably will be for
computer in real life but we think it'll
be pretty good we think that we will
have a pretty good product here and this
will have pretty solid frequencies or
other TCR latencies alright between
zones what could we learn like I said
you can just run the script again
there'll be a script for this you can
generate these very pretty bands you can
see again there are too big
for how our clusters work depending upon
basically fabric and we have a policy on
distance so that's you're talking
basically 220 microseconds or 270
microseconds when you're wanting to go
between zones and GCE over TCP it's
moderately fast those are our largest
zones and regions and then there's the
fringe zones that are a little bit
faster to the right and a little slower
to the left the little ones that are
closer to the right those are almost
always caused by somewhat considerably
smaller zones we have a few zones like
like the Montreal zone that was on an
earlier slide that are very close to
each other physically and so they have
incredibly better time so I mean the
times are substantially better for those
and again going all the way to the left
there are a few zones that have tails
and those are on upgraded zones as I
said Asia is one of those areas speed of
light very important for some for many
applications is transiting from this
graph is really hard to read from one
geo to another and this is all of our
interconnects between every zone in GCE
and this is almost entirely I it's not
that interesting of a slide in that it
is almost entirely generated from from
from speed of light and fiber plus a
couple how many hops if you are a little
bit inconsistent in your routing but
generally it is it follows that none of
those numbers almost exactly one
interesting thing from this graph is if
you can take a look very carefully it's
really hard about three-quarters of the
way up we see a slight change in the
CDF's
as you around 3/4 for a number of the
lines this was caused by a routing
glitch we had in early February or last
week of Feb 2
to monitor your cloud and find out if
you if you lost like 6 milliseconds this
is in milliseconds by the way for your
routing because of a small routing
glitch
finally I think this is the final slide
for data it is a networking throughput
networking throughput for GCE is pretty
compared to other clouds or in general
is pretty generous we give 2 gigabits
per second per core and that is not
throttled in some kind of mechanism so
that's a lot of it's a lot of bandwidth
to give on a per core basis this caps
out today I don't remember our Docs but
I think I'm safe to say it caps out at 8
cores so it's 16 Giga bits is where we
cap out there's a lot of there there's a
lot of work on going to increase that
number and in the subsequent weeks
months you should be seeing
announcements that that that we have
gone considerably higher on a per core
basis where we increased the caps but
this is where we are today and there's a
CDF yet again a percentile vertical
horizontal is throughput and you can see
most of the time you will get on your n1
standard eights you will get at each of
each line is a zone you will be getting
your 16 gigabytes a second once in a
while it will drop down some zones drop
down more commonly than others again
older fabrics generally is where you'll
see more of the issues on the tails
alright next and we can try the demo
let's see I'm almost at my last dregs
here of power and to see ds2 CDF's
the c2 and an n1 standard for I don't
remember what zone the n1 standard for
was in you can see the tails are
fantastic on the c2 this is again almost
certainly an artifact number one of the
high frequency of the c2 and secondarily
of them being in close physical
proximity this is with essentially with
placement groups even though it wasn't a
placement group API it was that they
happened to be there because we had very
limited quantities at the time but the
numbers are fantastic 38 microseconds
almost a p99 almost no tails we hope
that we can deliver this relatively soon
in large clusters
back to the den back to the slides
already oh I forgot there's more block
devices remote block devices are just
like networking and that they're
complicated there they have all
networking problems
plus they have media problems they are
very complicated to benchmark correctly
there are many SKUs every cloud has a
bunch of different SKUs every zone is
completely different due to fabric being
different being due to the generation of
the media being different cloud is
always like this we're always buying
different media as the generations go
along so there's a little bit of
inconsistency there load the media
almost always or quite commonly gets
slammed especially for spinning rust but
even SSD gets slammed continually for
these remote block devices so they're
all very highly subbed and so this
causes a variance in many different ways
and this all varies on a zone region
even time basis so benchmarking this is
moderately hard drive sizes modify the
performance you'll see in many complex
ways that are not easily intuited number
one obviously we tell you on the webpage
you'll get this many eye offs per
gigabyte and everyone else has a very
similar model but furthermore it turns
out that the internal programming of
these things means that larger discs
have a little bit more compute necessary
to figure out where the to do the LBA to
pba translations and that little bit
more compute makes it so that they're
just a little bit slower so you have to
try different drive sizes and they all
have different characteristics so it's
just really hard and throttling the
throttling because every cloud has block
devices that are some very hard they're
very hard they're subbed to a very high
degree they have very complex throttling
mechanisms so you have to understand the
throttling mechanisms that every cloud
has before you benchmark them so anyway
that's all this to say block devices
sadly are pretty complicated but we can
just try random reads because random
reads are easy so let's make a device
that's on this size 500 gigabytes in
size throw some random reads against it
and see what happens
this is pretty easy and it turns out for
us the bands are pretty tight actually
they're on the order of six hundred
millisecond or microseconds and the
interestingly you wouldn't know this
from external but I can just say that's
about half and a half in terms of
infrastructure problem infrastructure
time in terms of networking and media
and about half of that is computed there
is a VAT like I was saying the
computation to figure out where to store
the blocks and how to encode them is
moderately complicated and this is
pretty common across all the clouds that
that computation is actually a large
portion of the expense and you'll see
numbers around 600 or slightly around
there for most clouds for random for 4k
random reads the standard random writes
a little more random in terms of
performance you have a couple of zones
that are having that obviously where in
this case the media is quite subbed and
so these are SSD again where they are
pushing the media hard and the media is
a little bit older generation but the
vast majority is on the order of 450
microseconds you may be wondering how is
a write faster than I read because I
know how as this T's work writes are
incredibly hard it's because just like
most drives everyone has a little bit of
a cheat
we have battery-backed computers that
back all of our SSDs so we triple write
to three computers that are battery
backed and I was told by the storage ta
TL that I actually battery backed at
least three times
we are battery backed and it goes to
three machines and then when quorum is
achieved then we let you continue and
then asynchronously it is flushed to the
to the media in summary that was a lot
of data slides I'm sorry but this is
what they pay before it's all right put
you through that cloud is dynamic and
boot times are really what power that
dynamism please take advantage of quick
boot times use your computers only when
you need them and turn them off you'll
save lots of money and everyone wins and
you'll push us harder and harder to be
better and I like that is is complex but
to a first order you can benchmark this
pretty easily and
pretty cheaply all of those graphs like
our graphs the ones I had that were in
light green have more sample points but
they cost at most hundred bucks but and
I probably went too crazy on some of
those graphs you can make cheaper graphs
for a couple bucks and you can get a
good idea of what's going on the c2
we're pretty happy with it so far in all
of our testing we think this will be a
fine machine please go buy them and make
my capacity planners really upset they
don't know how they're gonna buy enough
so quickly and I hope you all go out
rush out and buy the c2 it's fantastic
and most importantly don't trust me
don't trust anything you saw here these
will be easy to run go to that location
there will be a directory with demos in
it really soon I have people working on
finishing the code and getting it
through code review right now so within
a few days there should be a place there
and you can just press up I roll like I
did and get numbers and maybe believe
them thank you
[Applause]
[Music]